the nevada gop once again alleging voter
fraud in the 2020 election and a new
lawsuit just announced this afternoon
this one joins a list of others filed in
recent weeks despite no evidence of any
widespread voter fraud or
mana joining us live from the party's
headquarters with more on this latest
legal challenge orca
well david this is the fifth lawsuit the
nevada gop
and the trump team have filed they
continue to claim that there was major
voter fraud
in the 2020 election despite providing
no concrete evidence a lawyer for the
trump campaign
even saying president trump won here in
nevada
the trump campaign filed this latest
lawsuit in carson city district court
this afternoon to contest the election
results
final numbers show joe biden beat
president trump by nearly 35 000 votes
in nevada
the legal challenge largely includes
allegations we've heard before
including that more than 15 thousand
people voted both in nevada and another
state
voters who are listed as dead voted and
that the signature verification machine
in clark county was not reliable
this all comes back to the
unsubstantiated claim that nevada's
expanded mail-in voting system
resulted in irregularities nevada and
clark
county have created this crisis
reckless unsolicited mail-in
voting has created
this crisis
the nevada secretary of state who by the
way is a republican has consistently
said
there is no evidence of widespread voter
fraud clark county officials also just
came out with a statement
saying the trump team and gop are quote
parroting erroneous allegations made
bipartisans
without firsthand knowledge of the facts
and it's important to note that most of
the lawsuits and legal challenges
filed by the trump team have been
rejected by the courts
there is one case pending in federal
court
reporting live in las vegas tonight orc
omana 8 news now